hey what's up everyone its Jon from
atlas i am the VRA
and I am going to show you what i do
when i started the conception to demo
basically after a little bit of
exposition you'll find yourself looking
down on this the world of a terra and
this is kind of where like everyone's
hanging out and all the disciples are
gathering to learn and studying have all
their fun adventures and then go fight
deadly deadly deadly monsters so you're
going to start off here and we can check
the dorm room and just this kind of
where all your base actions happen you
can look at skills you can change your
equipment out and everything tactics is
actually you know if you want to
automate your battle stuff you can
change some of the base stuff I always
choose save MP so I don't waste any of
my mana in the dungeon on auto but you
probably won't want to do that when
you're starting out take your quests
rest pastime system is where you save
and load and all that good jazz team
edit is where you can build your teams
you can see right now we have our main
character our heroine foucault and our
first line of star children we've got a
gunslinger a sorta switch is a sword
warrior and a cleric pretty balanced all
around line which is good but we have
two more lines that are locked we only
unlock those ones you have three
children so the first thing we're off
the bat is going to be you want to make
more babies you'll notice down here
which says bond points bond points are
your how strong your relationship is
right now and you need bond points to
make star children so obviously that's a
big priority to boost up and you'll
notice up here where it says spring you
see these three little heart icons these
hearts represent the number of chances
we have to talk to the girls so we can
in the Academy you'll see all the girls
are listed and there's some that we
haven't unlocked yet and we can pick
which one we want to talk to you so
we'll start with marika explaining the
Naraka shows up and get your options
with the pic and you sometimes you think
oh this is going to be really obvious
I'm gonna say hi to you alright like I
came to get you fired up that seems like
the right thing to say
a and then she winds up getting angry at
you so all the seven girls have their
own individual personalities Chloe Chloe
is actually clots as sister and she's so
smart that she's a teacher here's Elly
Elly is a fan favorite of our office but
I think she's gotten a week to start off
with but she's uh think she's a fire
elemental or she has fire elemental
attacks which are really helpful for the
second dungeon so it's not a bad idea to
start off with Ellie down here you have
some lesser dorks like clots your best
friend you can talk to you this kind of
helps reveal more story about the game
is about the relationships but it's not
necessary for improving relationships
with the heroines yeah so we talked to
him in our bond point was 50 now is 135
so we did fairly good job talking with
him but the good news is we have enough
to make a baby and we'll pick let's see
let's make a child with marika mature
oak is here are what you little vessel
that contains the Starchild so you'll
occasionally when your dungeons you can
find rare ones or ones that help boost
stats which are really helpful to unlock
some of the more advanced start classes
if you don't want to spend all the time
grinding out these dad so you meet in
this ritual hall and then it's time to
make us our child which sounds
complicated but really all it is is
holding hands and then magic happens
actual magic not figurative magic
so here you can see the star children
over here you'll see what stats you need
to make them if you're under those stats
you can't really start off with that so
you see we're really close to being able
to make a merchant and we do actually
have access to a grappler which is a
strong a fairly strong unit early on so
we'll make a grappler you can select a
random name or we can switch our own we
can check out the dorm room you'll see
we have our line set up here we can
and edit because we don't have three
babies we can't make a new line so we
have the option of swapping one out
which we could do might not be the best
idea but what the hell so since this
demo we're about to go through our very
first labyrinth we could do a cool
airship here fly off and go to our first
labyrinth we also get the option to pick
which Heron winter bring with us so
choose wisely you can also skip around
floors too once you've unlocked them but
since we are starting out fresh go into
the beginning get these fun little
transformation sequences again totally
okay if you make up your own song to go
with this music because you'll hear it a
lot foucault do wheels can't go wrong
with that and there's some weird like
pistol blade things so you'll be in this
dungeon and usually when you start out
the first thing you'll see this green
glowy thing and you'll go over here and
it says push X and when you push X it
gets you right back outside the dungeon
it's you're basically a little skate
point and there's one on every level
which is nice but don't press it because
then you have to go through that whole
sequence again these are little
containers they usually have like
potions or mana stuff but they also
contain sometimes I have weapons
sometimes they have other cool things
too so right here a little purple thing
in the middle of the room that's a
monster can go up and attack it we can
sort of skate around it to get to this
first Google potion potions are helpful
um so now we'll fight it
so there's a couple things the game it
explains to a little bit before you get
here but here's your chain drive meter
if you see this little white hash mark
over the are once we get there we'll
lock them down this guy is too weak
where we can really take advantage of
that down here this is your ether
density ether density the higher it is
the more chance you have to crit the
faster your guys are so you get put in
to take more turns before your enemy
over here we have our your standard
attack stuff can I'd our tactics guard
item skills or attack don't ya too low
level to have any skills so we'll just
beat this guy up you'll see if we can
move them around these cardinal
directions blue arrow is just a normal
attack this red arrow or orange arrow is
going to be his weak point so he's weak
to the right into the back and you can
attack them from the flank and then we
have at the turn for our line of star
babies we gotta put them in the same
spot or wherever we like what time you
know we'll make them choose us or them
beat them up experience obviously his
experience glow is your money value if
you build up your chain dry then lock an
enemy down you can actually recover some
bond points to which is a nice strategy
oh so that was actually a little piece
of equipment we got so we can go to the
clip here and we will go to equip select
one of our child so our grapplers kind
of our tank he's probably at the most
events so I'll give him a little bit
more you can see the blue is for stat
increases red will be a stat decrease
you can see out here so obviously don't
want to do that we also have the option
of doing this team best equipped this
will equip your little dudes with the
best equipment available just very nice
um this blue thing blue is good blue is
down green is out so we will we'll skip
this month oh there's a lot of monsters
room we'll skip those the first time
you'll eat your go down the floor you
need the boss monster this dude Asmodeus
he shows up and he's super pissed off
you see a bunch of monsters so Asmodeus
is here and he's pissed off and M&E
purple and you're like whoa WTF mate why
is this dude all angry and pissed off
boss lady's like hey you should probably
not fight that because your level one in
total noob and you being the protagonist
is like I got this naturally this is
going to end well
so let's see what we can do against them
we have skill nope no skills in La Ti
cuz we're still total noobs we're gonna
beat him up from the weak point he's
gonna stay away from my babies man I
will murder you don't like him hitting
my babies all right so he is charging
attack you can see right now where it
says caution well you can see hopefully
glowing letters that say it says caution
take my word for it if we attack them
from those will actually build our chain
drive very quickly so we should be able
to hopefully lock them down which we
didn't and we get punched in the face
for oops
we still should be okay here we go now
we're going to lock this fool down so
you activate her chain drive you can see
he's got the red chains coming on the
floor his turned in good push back
because again we're not super high level
enough but we got one level of chain on
him gonna take a second turn Oh third
turn go go go ah crap he's killed our
babies can I bring those guys back to
life cannot I don't have a revival
potion that was some stellar playing on
my part but now he's dead and we can do
a little dance because we did the chain
drive we got some bonus experience bonus
money and bonus bonus point or bond
points bonus bonus points that's crazy
talk yeah bonus bond points so once we
have all those got a new skill she got a
frost spell and our babies and get
experience because they were dead don't
let your babies be dead when you kill
something so we beat him yay but he
comes back to life and her boss is like
hey dumbass we knew this was gonna
happen but you didn't listen to us
that's why we tell you things like don't
fight on run away now I get chewed out
but we are God's gift so they can't say
too mad at us give us a second chance
and let's go back in so we're back out
of the dungeon our chances to talk to
people have improv Lenna Sh so let's go
talk to more people stick with norika so
let's see do we wanna grab
the deed do we want to talk for a bed do
we want to study together she seems like
the studious type so off the study and
then we call her up tight that probably
was not the right choice uh so she's got
a student council meeting soon it has to
go so we can say hey let's ditch it
let's let's not do that that seems like
the wrong choice let me see she waited
for us so we can either lend her a hand
make a donation or help gather
volunteers so gather volunteers she
seems to that seemed to cheer up a
little bit so hopefully hopefully we
salvaged that we got 37 bond points talk
to Ellie for a little bit he did you two
talk to Chloe song she kind of brushes
this off but now we have more than 100
bond points so we can make another baby
so make a baby with coal
may be rich whoa Omega let's make some
more magic damage magic damage can't go
wrong with here we go our baby is named
you might notice that they're getting
the hair color from their mother so
let's go to the dorm room real quick
make our damaged line so we're going to
switch these guys around we have our
gunslinger get our grappler wrecked and
then we're going to add in our magician
noob so we have the line of get rekt
noob you're welcome internet but we did
this take out our cleric which is
probably not a good idea so instead of
going back into the dungeon to replenish
our things we can also rest heart meters
refilled back to the Academy let's talk
to some more ladies hello foucault so we
just finished talking up with Foucault
now let's talk to na Rica do and see
America laying out with this part of the
way so we'll play nice with her and then
let's finish up by talking to Chloe
Colossus to go talk to her will show up
let's ask her if she's busy she's a
teacher we should respect her time klotz
wants us to carry comics and she totally
figures a milk so yeah we're gonna die
them out because well just because we
can and threw the match editing we have
a bunch of new bond points so we're
gonna make some more children let's see
Chloe's up close super piss ass so we'll
make a child with Foucault
ah yes again totally okay to see oh look
we we got lucky and we actually had
twins so their stats look to be about
the same but we can make everyone so
let's make a another gun slinger for
some damage since we had twins will nae
mam wing ghus twin boys and let's see
gunslinger and magician of course lingus
is twin has to be dingus
okay so with those twins we now have
enough for nine star children which is
something you're gonna want to do fairly
early on so let's go back to our dorm
room and you see we have this third row
unlocked here go down the team edit you
see we have recommended here you can
actually change and say I want to have
this form recommended teams let's see
change this to attack change this to
magic attack and change this to defend
the form its teams and it'll put
everything in its little recommended
settings hop back in the labyrinth and
again we can switch up our heroine make
sure we're giving some equal experience
to them so he had foucault originally
she's level three now let's go with
Ellie and you can see when you select
the labyrinth we have the option of
going back at the first floor or you
could select whichever floor you'd like
to so here's Ellie's transformation
transpose
duh Ellie's has a really high magic
attack value so she's one of those ones
once you level up you can unlock some of
the more magic intensive classes but you
can see now we have all the little
babies running around the blue haired
grappler from norika and the gunslinger
so yeah all the children inherit their
mother's hair colors you can see over
there we have little green haired
sorters from ali money around and yeah
then we're back in dungeon crawling mode
so sometimes you'll find these little
springs that can recover life we'll
leave that alone for now in case we need
it later and we'll start fighting some
monsters so now that we have three fold
lines you can see we have you can see we
have down here all four of us are taking
turns before this guy and we have some
skills now know you have skills as we
just start off with Ali
but now some of our magic babies have
skills so you'll notice they can occupy
the same space as their parents but you
can't have it as the same spot of stuff
so they can't go over here but they can
go to the weak spot so we'll do a magic
attack and wreck them in the face we
have another magic deck with four knees
so you can see there's a tactics tap
here and this is again how we can the
thing so we'll have everyone do save MP
save MPs better than no skills because
if someone's low your clerical actually
heal you speed up combat so it goes a
little faster and triangle will do full
auto so if this is more your speed and
want to get through some earlier
dungeons or grind out some experience to
level up your babies this is a good way
to kind of go on cruise control but you
want to keep an eye out because
sometimes they can't throw a little
curveballs your way and if you're not
paying attention like I did one time you
will wind up with a very very very dead
party oh and I'll show you this meka
night you'll see this is what we until
earlier where your children can turn
into a giant byline death robot this is
very alright this uses the base element
that your children have so that's why
you want to have no similar elements of
kids on the same team if that's your
speed but meki night rook what uses
these bond point so it's gonna take I
think a hundred to turn them into this
giant death mech that and important
thing know is that these have their own
life bar so if you have a bunch of kids
that are almost dead and you don't have
to turn to heal them you can MEK unite
them and they'll have this base attack
so we have skills get to it does yeah so
this also has its skills available um
limited by the amount of mana
and as you can see I totally wrecked
that thing of course it's a level one
little bat which hopefully wouldn't have
given us much trouble normal you guys
wanted to show you guys later dungeons
skills become apical and there's a lot
of skill to they're not just attack
skills there's buffs and debuffs and it
all depends on your party classes like
there's a few classes that are like peer
support like a minstrel just like a bard
class that plays songs to speaking so
this is funny so you see this little sad
looking guy right here this means that
we're actually too high a level and the
fight would be totally meaning so i can
walk up to him and zap him in the face
so he dies without having to go into
combat but we still get the experience
from it which is nice you can see the
Lord says level up down there that's a
that's kind of a quick and dirty way to
powerlevel your any newborn babies you
might have if you like switch out a full
line of them you're going to be in
trouble like if you have three level
ones in like a dungeon where monsters
are level 15 if they take one hot shot
at your kids they're all gonna die so
you can take him out yeah now that we
have three sets of children the first
dungeons pretty you know this one's not
gonna be super difficult for us so your
play the grind through level up as many
babies as you want you know obviously
they'll if you go through with two it's
gonna be a little bit harder for you if
you go through with one it's gonna be
really hard but yeah make sure you have
a lot of full set of babies early on for
getting through this quickly because you
absolutely cannot get through the second
dungeon without a full set of them
there's a couple more things in the demo
I don't wanna go into them too much
because lets you guys went out for
yourself but that's kind of how i would
recommend starting out and hopefully you
learned a couple things for to
conception tubes coming out march 25
alright the conception two demos coming
out march 25th with hook which hopefully
is today and the game is going to be
launching on april fifteenth and we hope
you guys enjoy it
you